hello everyone I hope you all safe and
sound in your bubbles
this video is to quickly update you on
what the council has been working on to
help residents facing uncertainty due to
Co vat19 all councillors meet today
following a workshop on council budgets
last week the outcome was a clear
message that savings must be found we
know that everyone has been affected in
some way by the virus and locals facing
hardship will be anxious about upcoming
rates we have a significant rebate
scheme and range of options available
specifically designed to help so please
get in touch with any concerns we have
sharpened our pencil and are reviewing
our draft annual plan to make sure any
future rates increases are as low as
possible we can't yet confirm the
numbers a trust we are working hard on
this and we'll update you as soon as
possible
in short we want to cushion the impact
on families on the immediate future but
don't want to make any quick or
ill-considered decisions that have
long-term financial consequences install
Waimakariri bouncing back over the years
the council has been regarded as one
that displays common sense is
responsible and shows great care and
empathy for its people in the community
please be assured that all members of
the council are united and via desire
and commitment to the path to the
community I don't want to talk for too
long but you can read the full statement
of intent on the council's website I
hope that you're all well be kind stay
safe stay home and look after one
another
you